[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 19
janvier
ancien maire de montigny le bretonneux
et ex-président de saint quentin en
yvelines il est désormais sénateur
michel laugier nous avons pu le suivre
au palais du luxembourg il sera aussi
notre invité pour cette émission
l'occasion d'évoquer les actualités
locales du moment métropole du grand
paris est l'une 18 notamment dans le
reste de l'actualité retour sur les
voeux en commun des départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine la
ministre de la santé en déplacement à
plaisir ou encore les mairies qui ont
désormais la charge du stationnement est
payant pas toujours une bonne nouvelle
pour les automobilistes
plus de six mois après les élections
législatives les responsables de la
france insoumise dans les yvelines se
mobilisent à nouveau à travers des
réunions ouvertes aux citoyens organisés
comme vous le voyez dans des brasseries
ou des lieux publics le but réfléchir à
des thématiques qui font l'actualité
faire vivre le mouvement localement les
explications de randy nîmes aux
militants yvelinois au micro de nicolas
landry concrètement donc chacun va
présenter pendant cinq dix minutes un
sujet présente ce soir je vais présenter
la réforme de dieppe et après on en
parle pendant cinq dix minutes et on
essaie de créer des arguments ensemble
comment se porte la france insoumise
dans les yvelines
très bien on s'organise petit à petit et
on a
beaucoup d'actions qui sont mises en
place on soutient les initiatives
locales notamment les combats des
syndicalistes les combats des salariés
dans les entreprises on va les aider
enfin les appuie dans leur manifestation
dans leur regroupement
on est notamment membre du front social
politique toujours je vous le disais en
titre les caméras de tv et 78 ont pu
suivre le nouveau sénateur yvelinois
michel laugier au palais du luxembourg
un changement de décor et de mandat
important pour celui qui a été maire de
montigny le bretonneux pendant 13 ans il
sera d'ailleurs avec nous sur ce plateau
pour en parler mais d'abord reportage au
sénat regardez sous les dorures du sénat
michel laugier discute avec un collègue
parlementaire des enjeux du plateau de
saclay preuve qu'au palais du luxembourg
le local n'est jamais très loin surtout
pour l'ancien maire de montigny le
bretonneux et ex-président de saint
quentin en yvelines 78
voilà et là vous avez donc tous les
sénateurs du 78 j'ai des contacts
réguliers avec les maires des six flynn
et j'ai bien sûr des dossiers sur
lesquels bien je peux m'investir un peu
plus parce que je les connais puisque
c'est moi que les initiés dont
aujourd'hui on c'est plus facile parce
que avant j'avais certaines barrières
aujourd'hui en tant que parlementaire ça
m'ouvre les portes au sommet de l'état
les portes ouvertes du sommet de l'état
et celle très importante de l'hémicycle
sur le siège 159 précisément temps marc
angers je suis au centre
voyez dans ceux subis situé au centre
d'un lieu emblématique et historiques ou
ont siégé de nombreux ministres et
président de la république ça vous
permet aussi de penser à tout ce que
vous avez fait pour arriver où vous êtes
tout simplement dont voilà c'est avec un
peu de
fierté effectivement que je me suis
installé dans le fauteuil qui était à
mon nom depuis son arrivée il ya quatre
mois au sénat michel laugier l'ancien
journaliste s'est notamment vu confier
un rapport sur la situation de la presse
dans un contexte de crise seuls digital
montrent que de croissance dynamique
mais ils ne représentent encore en
moyenne que ce 1% du chiffre d'affaires
des éditeurs
j'ai procédé pendant plusieurs semaines
à des auditions de tous les
professionnels du us du secteur que ce
soit des fédérations des représentants
de journaux la presse quotidienne la
presse de province aussi et il a donc
j'ai rendu un rapport dont j'ai analysé
toutes là toute la situation et j'ai
jeté mon avis sur le budget qui était
proposé des enjeux d'ordre national d
audition de ministre et l'un des plus
beaux palais de la république
finalement seule la taille de son bureau
rappelle à michel laugier qu'il est un
sénateur fraîchement élu et voilà et
nous sommes donc avec michel laugier
sénateur des yvelines en plateau bonsoir
bonsoir
le reportage qui vient d'être diffusé
termine sur une touche d'humour est ce
que est ce que c'est vrai ce qu on a
l'habitude de penser peut-être que la
taille du bureau d'un sénateur sans
fonction de l'expérience des années
passées
est ce que c'est vrai au sénat est ce
que c'est en fonction de ça que vous
avez peut-être un petit bureau
fonctionnel mais pas très grand il ya un
petit peu de vérité donc tout ce qui se
passe c'est qu'en ce moment au sénat il
ya des travaux importants et bien sûr on
peut pas avoir accès à lançon au des
bureaux puisqu'ils sont en travaux donc
pour le moment c'est une situation
provisoire et j'espère dans quelques
temps pouvoir entrer dans un bureau
légèrement plus confortable alors vous
avez été élu fin septembre dès le mois
d'octobre vous siégiez au sénat on l'a
rapidement entendus dans notre reportage
mais dites nous comment comment comment
vit-on ses premières semaines
dans cette assemblée ce palais qui a
maintenant 223 ans le sénat à 223 ans il
ya des politiques on l'a dit qu'ils sont
passés des présidents et autres comment
comment vit ces moments alors c'est des
moments qu'on vit de manière assez
spéciale pour moi puisque j'étais
toujours maire de montigny et président
de l'agglomération et je devais aussi
faire mon entrée au sénat dont c'est des
moments qui sont pas toujours simples à
gérer alors s'éveille à cette fierté ce
bonheur de pouvoir siéger dans ce beau
palais de la république
mais quelque part aussi vous aviez aussi
le souci de la succession de tout ce qui
allait se passer dans les
responsabilités qui était le vôtre
aujourd'hui vous êtes sommes pleinement
sénateur vous êtes l'esprit un peu plus
libre aujourd'hui je suis j'ai l'esprit
libre du sénateur j'ai la sagesse du
sénateur pour aborder tout
aujourd'hui les décisions que je serai
amené à prendre parce que je regarde que
maintenant au niveau local les choses
sont bien installés et lévis quantité on
a plus de temps de travailler sur les
dossiers quand on est sénateur que
peut-être quand on a des éléments de
mandats locaux vous le disiez aussi
l'iran of mais on vous appelle plus le
soir quand il ya des problèmes avec la
police municipale ou où les pompiers ça
ça permet de prendre du temps de voir
les choses différemment avait une autre
qualité de vie bien sûr vous avez
d'autres boyen mais vous avez aussi de
des ressources et est importante puisque
vous devez voter la loi vous devez
contrôler le gouvernement dont ce sont
quand même des responsabilités
importantes mais pour ça bien il faut
effectivement travailler il faut être
investis et c'est vrai que j'ai un
emploi du temps aussi qui est chargé
mais par rapport à ce que je faisais
avant
ce n'est pas la même responsabilité qui
pèse sur vos épaules du moins au
quotidien et dans l'urgence alors
forcément vous avez gardé un ancrage
local dû à votre nouvelle fonction mais
aussi parce que vous êtes toujours
conseiller départemental vous n'êtes
plus conseiller municipal à montigny
pourquoi avoir fait le choix cette fois
ci de garder votre votre poste au
département pas tout simplement parce
que je souhaitais garder
un ancrage local ça me paraît important
pour un parlementaire de bien connaître
ce qui se passe sur le terrain
et finalement la meilleure des
situations c'est d'être élu leur ensuite
par rapport aux responsabilités qui
étaient les miennes dans l'exécutif
quand vous êtes patron de l'exécutif
local que ce soit la ville de manzini ou
à l'agglomération
je me voyais mal rester dans la salle
être dans un coin ça aurait été
difficile pour moi et puis appartement
où j'ai fait un choix
eh bien je laisse l'entière
responsabilité à ceux qui aujourd'hui
assumer les fonctions qui étaient les
miennes et encore quelques temps est-ce
que vous restez curieux tout de même de
voir ce qui se passe très localement par
exemple à montigny le bretonneux ce que
vous pouvez voir renseigner directement
auprès du nouveau maire par curiosité un
personnel je me renseigne pas puisque
jean-luc hugo est un ami depuis
longtemps toute l'équipe municipale en
place est bien ce qu à moi qui les
choisit donc j'ai toujours des relations
privilégiées avec mes élus mais surtout
avec la population vous savez je reste
iny montrent un je vais faire mes
courses je prends les transports en
commun pour aller au sénat dont je
croise énormément de personnes et c'est
cette qualité finalement mois de vie qui
m'intéresse c'est toujours être en
contact dont je vais être un élu
national mais avec un véritable ancrage
local
en tout cas il ya des sujets locaux qui
vous concerne forcément en tant que
sénateur c'est le cas par exemple du
projet de la métropole du grand paris
les annonces du gouvernement sont
attendus mi février les départements eux
s'inquiètent toujours de leur éventuelle
disparition d'une métropole qui serait
limitée à la petite courage ces sujets
étaient d'ailleurs au coeur dès veut
comme un des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine mardi reportage de
michael et demi d'euros panneau lumineux
géant pin's pétition à l'entrée le ton
est donné les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine refuse la future
métropole et l'ont fait savoir ce mardi
soir lors de leur cérémonie de voeux
commune
ce redécoupage étudiés par l'état vise à
créer une métropole de rang mondial
limité à paris à la petite couronne exit
les autres départements de la région
parisienne dont les yvelines
on nous parle de simplification
mais c'est pour inventer à chaque fois
de nouvelles usines à gaz qui nous
contraignent à des dépenses d'énergie et
d'argent considérables sans jamais
produire le moindre bénéfice mesurable
il mesure qui mettrait en péril la
fusion entre les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine à rapprochement opéré
depuis 2016 vous avez une voiture qui
est en panne une voiture qui marche
vous prenez pas la voiture qui marche
pour réparer la voiture qui est en panne
c'est ce qui est en train de faire le
gouvernement et ça ça m'agace parce que
c'est dramatique
ça nous mettra tous à pied là où il
faudrait qu'on monte dans une voiture
qui est celle de la croissance dans leur
sillage les présidents des cinq autres
départements d'île de france ont pris la
parole au pupitre ou via des vidéos pour
dénoncer ce futur redécoupage le
socialiste le communiste l'homme de
droite tous ceux gens sont ensemble sont
d'accord il faut décentraliser parce que
un service public qui fonctionne c'est
un service qui est à proximité des
besoins des usagers pour la république
en marche ce scénario n'est pas encore
tranchée l'elysée devrait communiquer
dans les prochaines semaines sur le
nouveau statut de cette métropole
tout dépend des compétences qui seront
affectés aussi aux différentes entités
je pense en tout cas ce qui est attendu
c'est plus d'efficacité et plus de
simplicité parce qu'aujourd'hui nos
concitoyens et savent pas forcément
qu'elle est l'entité pertinente pour
quelles actions à mener pour apaiser les
tensions la soirée s'est clôturée par
des concerts de musique classique la
chanson devrait être différent dans les
prochains jours sur la scène politique
régionale le 31 janvier les sept
présidents de départements se
rassembleront de nouveau à
boulogne-billancourt pour défendre une
métropole régionale michel laugier vous
étiez présent ce soir et mardi soir quel
serait l'impact concrètement par exemple
pour saint quentin en yvelines pour
montigny le bretonneux pour le
département des iv si jamais la
métropole rester dans son schéma actuel
c'est-à-dire qui exclut la grande
couronne bien servir tout simplement que
la région ile-de-france évoluerez à deux
vitesses ce qui est inacceptable
evènement tous les moyens seraient mis
sur cette métropole ça veut dire qu'il
resterait plus grand chose pour les
autres départements périphériques et en
plus aujourd'hui on ne sait toujours pas
on ne sait toujours pas ce qui va se
passer
parce que yayi a débarqué dans la presse
visant mais vous avez l'idée l'idée
aujourd'hui de paris et des départements
de première couronne
mais vous avez aussi une option qui
serait aussi d'intégrer cette nouvelle
organisation roissy parce que comment
faire une région qui a ils ont une
compétence mondial si on n'a pas des
aéroports dont hong kong bondé roissy
orly plateau de saclay vélizy et la
partie la plus riche de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ski ça aussi
dans l'idée vous rendez compte aurait
séparé saint-quentin-en-yvelines
quasiment en exactement exactement droit
est ce que vous rendez compte de ses
décisions ce qui ferait que nous aurions
ensuite un département un territoire qui
serait à double vitesse mais avec une
première partie qui aurait bien sûr tous
tous les atouts et la deuxième partie
bien qu'ils ne vivraient que aux dépens
des autres en tant que sénateur aussi
avec vos collègues sénateur des yvelines
de l'essonne et autres est ce que vous
arrivez à avoir des informations à peser
sur un tel sujet ce que vous pensez que
que le gouvernement vous écoute sur sur
cette question là écoutez on saisit le
gouvernement on pose des questions vous
voyez bien que pour nos mandats aucune
réponse
ou alors c'est la période des sports
d'hiver on a à droit slalom dans les
dents les réponses qui ne sont faites
par les ministres
regardez bien toutes les décisions
importantes aujourd'hui on les
repoussent à plus tard la métropole on
devait on devait avoir une réponse avant
la fin de l'année et bien là on est
presque à la fin du mois de janvier nous
n'avons toujours rien et on sent pas que
quelque chose soit vraiment mûr ou alors
vous savez aujourd'hui le vrai problème
c'est que à la tête de l'état il ya
aussi beaucoup de personnes et qui n'ont
aucune aucune expérience locale et donc
ils ont du mal à mesurer l'impact sur
les collectivités
la question qui se pose aussi qui est
sous jacente c'est celle du millefeuille
territorial beaucoup disent qu'il ya un
échelon en trop vous vous êtes pour la
fusion entre la métropole et la région
est ce que ferait pas aussi pour six à
supprimer par exemple les départements
on voit que les intercommunalités ça
marche on prend 50 ans nevin ça marche
très bien
les communes sont évidemment intouchable
ce qui reste d'ailleurs c'est les
départements est ce que ça c'est pas une
bonne intention aussi de vouloir réduire
le nombre d'échelons pour fluidifier le
fonctionnement de la région vous savez
ce qui compte surtout ce sont les
compétences donner aux différentes
collectivités
il ya des collectivités quels à base de
mems d'autres organisations en france
c'est la comète auquel les français
et là je veux dire on ne fera rien il ne
faut absolument pas toucher aux communes
on voit bien je fais en ce moment
la tournée de beaucoup de voeux dans le
département des yvelines et quand on
voit quand quand on voit ce que les
maires font le travail
quand on voit tout ce qui est proposé
quand on voit que ça reste l'élément
essentiel dans la vie d'un pays
il ne faut pas y toucher alors ensuite
après le département reste aussi reste
aussi une instance proche des habitants
et en plus en avant le succès de l'arc
la jolie à rambouillet par exemple dans
les yvelines
alors on comprend le lien entre les
clayes-sous-bois et magny les hameaux
oui mais vous avez après justement à
faire un rééquilibre parce qu'à ce
moment là si vous prenez que la richesse
zone par zone
là il n'y a pas de redistribution donc
au niveau d'un département et regardez
bien le verger de ré les départements
des yvelines qui est un département très
urbanisée à certains endroits et qui est
très agricole dont d'autres un
département qui est très riche en
recettes économiques à certains endroits
et malheureusement dans d'autres
endroits c'est quand même des zones un
peu sinistrée eh bien c'est ce
rééquilibrage qui compte et je crois que
le département est là pour ça parce que
ça reste toujours une collectivité de
proximité et notamment bien sûr dans son
rôle au niveau social il y à un autre
sujet très important qui est évidemment
liée à la métropole du grand paris c'est
le supermétro aussi appelé le grand
paris express selon la cour des comptes
un rapport dévoilé cette semaine le coût
de ce projet monstrueux dérape on est
désormais à 38 milliards d'euros pour
construire 200 km de nouveau métro
contre 19 milliards en 2010 le
gouvernement pourrait donc décider
d'étaler dans le temps la construction
écoutez à ce propos la ministre des
transports elle devait s'exprimer mardi
au sénat justement on l'écouté ce projet
est crucial pour la région parisienne
et donc il sera mené à son terme le
schéma d'ensemble n'est pas remis en
cause
il n'est pas question de modifier le
schéma global de ce réseau du grand
paris des délais très ambitieux ont été
annoncées des délais dont je ne pense
pas qu'on puisse dire qu'ils sont
réalistes
quand on voit la complexité quand on
voit la complexité de construire 200 km
de métro automatique en souterrain
largement dans le sol très compliquée du
bassin parisien
alors il ya une bonne et une mauvaise
nouvelle dans ce que dit la ministre à
bonn c'est qu'on ne touchera pas au
schéma donc la ligne 18 devrait en tout
cas arrivé dans les yvelines en revanche
le calendrier on comprend clairement
même si ce n'est pas encore officiel
qu'il sera repoussée est ce que vous
êtes rassurés ou alors c'est pas du tout
positif pour vous non moi je suis
toujours inquiet si vous appelez tout à
l'heure le slalom mais vous avez la
réponse la ministre j'étais dans
l'hémicycle quand la question lui a été
posée et bien qu'on voit bien que
aujourd'hui on fuit on fille sur une
réponse précise
vous savez un étalement du calendrier ce
n'est jamais bon ça veut dire que
ensuite ce sont d'autres responsables
qui devront prendre la décision
on a bien vu ce que ça va donner avec
notre dame des landes
donc là on est un peu dans la grande et
vous savez que ça va ça va très vite la
ligne 18 on en parle déjà de plus de 10
ans donc l'âme alors ce n'est pas l'une
18e au départ mais en tout cas on est un
peu dans ce dans ce schéma là et dont je
moi j'ai pris rendez vous auprès de la
ministre je veux avoir une réponse ferme
de la mise
et je rappelle le cas même que lorsque
j'étais encore président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin nous
avons signé un courrier commun avec le
président doit que des d'agglomération
de l'aca grand parc
mon collègue aussi de paris saclay et
pierre bédier président du conseil
départemental lettre au premier ministre
lettre à laquelle nous sommes jamais eu
aucune réponse du premier ministre on
devrait avoir des réponses normalement
mi février mais je pense que la mode des
choses quand des élus s'adresse qu'aux
ministres c'est guy zitte de réponse
quelle que soit la réponse
moi je n'ai jamais laissé un courrier
sans réponse c'est de la responsabilité
politique
merci
laugier d'être venu en plateau et
d'avoir répondu à nos réponses nos
questions plutôt je rappelle que vous
êtes sénateur divers droite des yvelines
bon week-end à vous merci merci beaucoup
on passe au reste de l'actualité de la
semaine
en france un enfant sur cinq vit sous le
seuil de pauvreté un constat alarmant
pour les professionnels du secteur de la
petite enfance une concertation sur le
sujet a été lancé par le président de la
république emmanuel macron en octobre
dernier lundi une première rencontre se
déroulait à plaisir en présence d'agnès
busin ministre des solidarités de la
santé reportage de camille lambert
représentant de la caisse d'allocations
familiales des yvelines de la
croix-rouge ou d'associations en faveur
des plus démunis
ce sont eux les premiers acteurs de la
lutte contre la pauvreté et notamment
celle des enfants en présence de la
ministre des solidarités de la santé ils
ont fait part de leurs connaissances et
de leurs attentes
on a toujours des attentes sur la
question de la parentalité de la petite
enfance
d'autant que c'est quand même le premier
pied à l'étrier je dirais sur le lien
social et c'est ce qui a été évoqué par
madame la ministre
donc ça c'est déjà le premier point de
bien vous préciser que faire société
ça passe aussi et surtout parler tout
petit dans la tente et pouvoir peut-être
participer à des groupes de travail
parce qu'on a fait que évoqué ce matin
le sujet et qu'il faut approfondir en
france un enfant sur cinq vivraient sous
le seuil de pauvreté
cette journée marquait la première d'une
série de concertations lancées par le
gouvernement en octobre 2010 cet
objectif établir une stratégie de lutte
contre la pauvreté des enfants
nous voyons qu'il va falloir intervenir
sur le repérage l'identification des
besoins
sur l'accès aux droits sur la formation
des professionnels
ce que je note aussi c'est une
mobilisation et un engagement très fort
des acteurs de terrain avec énormément
d'initiatives locales
ça m'a permis de parler surtout des
dispositifs innovants en faveur de
l'enfance notamment l'espace bébé
parents qui est un lieu d'échangé lieu
d'accueil un dispositif que la
croix-rouge souhaitent développer en
milieu rural sous une forme itinérante
une dizaine d'autres rencontres de ce
type sont prévues partout en france
remise de la stratégie adoptée à l'issue
de ces réunions prévues fin mars au
président de la république et la
ministre de la santé a poursuivi son
déplacement lundi dans les yvelines elle
s'est rendue à poissy pour l'extension
du centre hospitalier intercommunal
poissy saint germain le plus important
d'île de france le nouveau bâtiment de
19 mille mètres carrés doit être livré
en 2020 pour un coût global estimé à 70
millions d'euros
la colère des agents pénitentiaires
perdure après une série d'agressions
dans plusieurs prisons de france et
notamment en corse encore vendredi matin
malgré des annonces et des rencontres
avec la ministre de la justice
la mobilisation se poursuit un peu
partout à bois d'arcy si le mouvement
n'est pas très important la situation
est pointé du doigt par les syndicats
comme nous l'expliqué mercredi soir sur
notre plateau le secrétaire local
adjoint de fo pénitentiaire
extraits aujourd'hui on est amené à
gérer des détenus de plus en plus
violents voire radicaliser ou en cours
de radicalisation pour certains et
malheureusement on n'a pas les moyens on
n'a pas les moyens matériels on n'a pas
les moyens humaines pour gérer ces
détenus dire que c'est très compliqué
pour nous deux
de faire face à ces actes violences faut
savoir que dans notre administration et
dans nos détention la violence est
quotidien que ce soit des insultes des
menaces ou des violences physiques
vous avez dit encore il ya quelques
jours à mont de marsan il ya sept agents
qui ont été blessés assez gravement
hier ça a été à tarascon ii mais ça peut
arriver à tout à fait si on relocalise
sur bois d'arcy on est dans un contexte
où on parle souvent de surpopulation des
prisons des maisons d'un verre un taux
d'occupation parfois 200 % qu'en est-il
la sueur sur bois d'arcy
on est quasiment à 200% c'est à dire
qu'on est à peu près à 1000 détenus pour
560 places donc c'est avec le même
nombre de surveillants qui a des années
voilà c'est très difficile pour nous
pour pour gérer au quotidien
il faut gérer des mouvements pour aller
à l'infirmerie des mouvements parloir
des activités et le surveillant l'heure
d'aujourd'hui il est débordé il peut
plus gérer un étage promis devrez gérer
une unité c'est l'un des changements qui
a accompagné la nouvelle année le
stationnement est devenue une compétence
des communes est désormais ce sont elles
qui fixe le tarif des amendes et dans
les yvelines en cas de non paiement à
l'horodateur les automobilistes devront
débourser de 15 à 35 euros selon les
villes le point avec camille lambert ne
dites plus pv mais fps forfait poste
stationnement c'est une nouveauté de
cette rentrée 2010 8 ce sont les villes
qui fixe elle même les prix de ces
nouvelles amendes de stationnement dans
les yvelines le tarif s'étend de 15 à 35
euros à guyancourt en cas d'absence de
tickets derrière le pare brise
il faudra payer 25 euros le but c'est
pas de d'obérer le pouvoir d'achat des
d'aiguillon courtois et c'est vraiment
qu'on est vraiment un turnover parce
qu'on est sur des zones où il ya quand
même certaines tensions où les gens
bougent peu et il les a aidé les
résidents sont pas mal plein donc on a
eu quelques remontées quand même à
proximité de la gare donc ça attire
beaucoup de monde donc voilà l'idée
s'était effectivement d'avoir un montant
qu'ils soient suffisamment dissuasif
mais non plus qui n'est pas qu'ils ne
sont pas du matraquage une augmentation
pour gagner en efficacité
d'autres communes ont fait ce choix
comme montigny le bretonneux passer à 25
euros
trapel en cours à 35 euros danser
cette zone plaisir maintient les 17
euros de l'ancien amendes pour les
automobilistes cette mesure est
dissuasive 17 euros déjà c'est pas mal
et en plus maintenant maintenance et
24/25 donc maintenant j'ai encore plus
gaffe tu en penses tu que je paye si
suis toujours relevé vous mieux payés
que de prendre une prune chaque moins
cher pendant c'est vrai que ça fait un
peu mal de payer 50 centimes pour de
moins de 10 minutes
quand on fait juste un aller retour
voilà après bon si ça peut vite être
payées 25 euros c'est quand même mieux
autre évolution le paiement de l'amendé
t'ajuster en fonction du dépassement de
leurs limites de stationnement si vous
avez déjà payé 10 euros ils seront donc
déduits et si la police municipale
s'occupe toujours du contrôle à
guyancourt
les communes pourront aussi faire appel
à des sociétés privées
les travaux ont débuté il ya presque
deux ans en mars 2016 c'est un chantier
d'envergure qui se déroule en ce moment
pour le site mgen de la verrière une
reconstruction totale des deux sites
rivière et forestier et opérer pour en
faire un seul établissement d'une
capacité de prêts de 500 lits le point
sur l'avancée des travaux avec mélanie
poquet ici pousse l'un des bâtiments
dédiés à la santé mentale depuis mars
2016 le site médical de la mgen la
verrière poursuit sa mue quarante mille
mètres carrés de surface plancher un
investissement de 100 millions d'euros
donc c'est pour la mgen un très gros
chantier
le chantier c'est un chantier et à haute
qualité environnementale effectivement
la certification d étude a été faite
et puis nous avançons et aujourd'hui sur
la réalisation avec une maîtrise des
nuisances au niveau du chantier
un chantier qui permet de fusionner les
deux sites historiques marcel rivière et
denis forestier jugé vétuste
la livraison du bâtiment santé mentale
est prévue pour la fin de l'année 2018
le centre denis forestier lui continue
son activité tels que lui ne viendra
comme je le disais précédemment qu'à la
fin la réalisation on l'a on transfère à
l'ensemble de nos patients et de nos
résidents nous avons la chance également
que toute la production restauration est
située sur le site rj hayatou denis
forissier donc on continue à livrer la
restauration du premier site comme celui
là si tu mens et la rivière sans aucun
impact pour nos pronos passion les
travaux sont prévus sur trois ans fin
2019 le site aura 4 185 lits ses 76 de
plus qu'auparavant
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo autour
de l'actualité en direct lundi à 18h sur
l'antenne de tv2 78 bon week-end à tous
et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]